hi guys this is ideas of ice and fire
and I decided to create this video
because after I uploaded my doom Masaya
video I created like this 20 minute
audio recording where I dived into some
of the deeper themes and just some of
the stuff that I wanted to talk about
that I didn't include in the video and
this video we're gonna talk a little bit
more well in this audio recording
because there's not gonna be much or any
editing in this we're gonna talk about
Latos sacrifice and the golden path no
link toast sacrifice is that he is more
human than anyone than anyone that's
ever lived
once he undergoes the spiced trance and
he and he takes on the symbiotes kinda
changes his consciousness in a really
crazy way because he is in God infer of
doom Leto can literally go back and live
through the life of a person in his
memory anyone he can pick any person
throughout human history
so he's the most human person but at the
same time he's not human anymore like he
can't even really have contact with a
person because the moisture in their
skin is gonna burn him because like the
like he's got a warm skin on basically
and water is poison to the worms so like
he is the most human yet he's not even
human anymore and that's a lot of
suffering and also he remembers all of
the pain of human history he remembers
all of that suffering he remembers all
of the pain so he's lived through World
War two and the Crusades he's been
tortured he's been like raped he's been
murdered like like the entire spectrum
of human experience Leto has experienced
it in full force it is not like Paul the
way he can just go back and look at
these memories and just kind of see them
from a different perspective Leto can go
back and live through these memories
like it's he's that powerful and there's
an immense burden that comes with that
watching every one that he will ever
love die and there's just so much
sadness to this character there's a
beautiful quote from God in / of dune
and this is basically these people still
Latos journals some of his journals
basically and they have all this stuff
that he's written in there throughout
the millennia and these words are
identified as words I wrote when told of
ghani's death and it says the sand beach
as gray as a dead cheek a green tide
flow reflects cloud ripples I stand on
the dark wet edge cold foam cleanses my
toes
I smell driftwood smoke so and it also
in the pages there's a flower and it's a
flower that uh Kadima gave him so but
the point is even though Leto was alone
when he put on that skin symbiote after
again Nima's death he was even more
alone he was truly alone once kanima
dies and yes she will die he will live
much longer than anyone else
so once kanima dies she's the only
person that even kind of shared his
experience like so that's why the end of
Children of Dune when Janina is talking
to Feridun she's like of course you
couldn't understand you don't know what
it's like to have all these memories
Leto has all these memories and he's not
human
so there's just an extraordinary amount
of sacrifice he's not a man anymore he
doesn't have genitals he can't like make
love with his own body there's just so
much stuff that he can't do because he
made this huge sacrifice for Humanity
and speaking of that sex speaking of the
sacrifice he made let's talk about the
Golden Path No
so the Golden Path you know there's a
lot that goes into it and a lot of it
will be a lot of it I'll explain in my
god improv dude video but essentially
he's leading Humanity on a path so that
they're not eventually extinct right so
what what he does in god improv dune is
the ascent he basically suppresses space
travel and he gives humans total other
peace other peace total peace and also
stagnation and be in in the the point
was to demonstrate that people don't
really like peace they need conflict so
after this happens
after he dies after Leto goes back into
the sands and yes that will happen
everything dies Leto goes back into the
sands and then people are allowed to
travel again space travel comes back and
people flee the Imperium people people
say we're gonna go further than we've
ever ever gone before
so humanity spreads out far beyond the
reaches of the Imperium so he's he has
made sure that humans will survive and
then there's there's another thing than
he did on top of that the plot that runs
through got in fur of Doon and and kind
of comes to conclusion and got him from
dune and the reason he took over the
bidding Jesuit breeding program in fact
he was trying to breed a human that he
couldn't see in prescence that but that
was oppressing it someone that wasn't
prescient that he couldn't see in
pressings he was trying to hide people
from treci ins for some reason from from
something that he calls the great enemy
and we don't know exactly what that is
of course in the Brian Herbert books we
get the remnants of the Machine Empire
and omnious and all that jazz we don't
know what Frank Herbert was going for we
know at the end of heretics we get a
really interesting scene where it's kind
of like you see these play like sue
based answers and you can see that's a
play back sue in their civilization
they're kind of like they're like on the
bottom I was like the face dancers on
like the bottom they're like the slave
race and the thing is at some point in
their history they got the ability to
absorb memories right and so they're
saying that how could they not think
that one day we would gather enough
memories to be even more because you get
enough memories and you're like the quiz
that's had a rack you can look into
those other memories and so they're kind
of like watching everyone you think what
are what what are these guys doing and
you have duck and Idaho in the later
books it actually gets a vision of them
and but that's way later and I shouldn't
even be talking about this has nothing
to do it'll go ahead too far going too
far but yeah the golden path
he's he's making sure humans survive
like this is the only future where
humans don't eventually go extinct is
what basically I take from it and so
Late Late 2 is also teaching humans a
lesson he says I promised them a lesson
that their bones would remember hisses
don't offer up your freedom to a
charismatic leader that's like the
essential point of it like he becomes
the tyrant to show them really what a
tyrant can do when he has absolute power
this is what a tyrant can do when he has
absolute power right and it's it's just
and also and I'm just gonna say this in
I don't know what the reactions gonna be
but this is showing you the horror of
absolute communism right a little bit of
socialism is good right but when it's
absolute and everyone it's just like
there's just absolutely one has the same
thing and there's that you can't really
move up in the society there's no space
travel but your total peace there's no
suffering you know in in Star Trek for
example still the communism it's it's
socialism it's total 100% socialism and
Star Trek they don't have money like
they like they help everyone like even
if you're like some random alien they'll
they'll give you medical care it's like
it's it's total socialism but in in dune
but it works in Star Trek it works
because people in Star Trek they work to
better themselves instead of like
working to make money they work to
better themselves but in god improv dune
it's communism socialism absolute
socialism plus the suppression of the
god Emperor and that just makes it
absolutely horrible because there's so
much they're just not allowed to do like
a Star Trek you do whatever you want but
in in in what Leto did you're not
allowed to do anything and but it's for
their own sake right in in Star Trek
humans have evolved as people you know
what just on a general level they've
evolved as people in a way that they're
just more compassionate more just
thoughtful but it but that's of course
unrealistic I love Star Trek but it's
unrealistic in reality Pia
people are not like that and so late oh
he had to suppress things to maintain
the peace and to maintain the you know
all that [ __ ] but it's more like the
illusion of peace as well it's not
totally peaceful right he-he's Keys
creating the illusion of peace but even
that it kind of created a restlessness
within the consciousness of mankind
right people were a restless in this
piece you know everyone lives in these
villages that are all the same and then
in you know Duncan Idaho he gets brought
back in every book like the hit when he
sees one of these villages from like the
sky he's like he's like are there more
villages like this in in someone
responds this is the shape of the Empire
right so people people don't like to
live like that people like to be
individuals and have different things
going on that's not allowed and Latos
Empire so he's just he's trying to teach
them a lesson he's he's living your
instincts and that just stagnation is
not good for people and then he's also
giving them incentive just to be like
when I'm dead flea run off into the
universe and don't trust leaders don't
don't put someone like me in power again
so we as humans are way too trusting of
our leaders or with someone that's
charismatic can show up and we'll just
totally trust them and we've always been
like that and we still are today and is
it is a problem it is a problem because
just because someone is charismatic
doesn't mean that they have your best
interest in mind that does not mean that
Ted Bundy was charismatic so so later
took the universe by force now it was
Paul that kind of won over the Freeman
with just by being charismatic and being
their hero basically but later overtook
the universe with force but dude it's
not just a criticism of the charismatic
leader
it's the criticism of like the system
that leads to like tyrants being born we
really should not stand idly by while
our freedoms get slowly scaled back if
your freedom is even touched a little
bit you [ __ ] scream bloody murder and
you say [ __ ] no and you you have to make
noise
although otherwise this is gonna keep
happening over and over again Frank
Herbert is showing you the cycle this
happened in the past
now happen in the future I think comic
book girl 19:7 on dune club by the way
check out doom Club come we're gonna
team but this is the way government's
work even if you have someone like Paul
that does care they're still gonna be
bad stuff that's happening he can't
completely stop all the bad to stop all
these people from getting killed he can
kind of make it good even if you have a
good person like him like still that
doesn't change the fact that eventually
someone like Leto is gonna come into
power and right that's the thing Leto is
okay with being viewed as the villain
because he is he says to manao a
character in God in front of duty says I
am a predator manao he says I am the
predator of humanity and he is but
humanity needed a predator we're too
comfortable need it you needed the
predator you need it the predator you
know to show you how to live in your
instincts it's like the last chapter of
Children of Dune humans by the end of
Krell exact but once again learn to live
in their instincts so I can't wait to I
get to actually making the ultimate
guide to God emperor of doing because it
is my favorite book and I can really go
deep into that one I feel like for this
got in free of doing video I'll kind of
do it'll be a little different I feel
like I can cover the story that happens
in that one in a short amount of time
and then I can go in and just really
dive deep into just Leto and it's in her
lives in just the Golden Path and you
know just the deeper themes that are
going on in that because the story is
kind of like the story and God number of
doing happens over the course of like I
don't even know very short amount of
time I want to say like a month maybe
like it happens very quickly I could be
wrong on that I could be wrong but I'm
thinking that it's like a very short
amount of time that the entire thing
happens but it's interesting basically
interestingly enough it opens up at an
even far as our time and if we don't
even know how far in the future this is
like you have people that are looking at
basically what we're seeing and I never
of Dune is told it's being read from
these like little exceed devices at Leto
left his there's like his journals he
hid these journals away
and like this is what people are reading
I guess I guess that kind of doesn't
make sense because um he does die in the
end so how could he have a journal of
his own death I guess he is prescient I
don't know let's not get into like
whatever but in the beginning of this it
opens up with people reading his
journals I don't know if everything in
the book is supposed to be from the
journal but you know you get what I'm
saying
in fact I'm pretty sure it can't be that
way because Leto said and got informed
in that he refused to look at his own
death he never looked at it so that
couldn't be okay
whatever that's not the point Children
of Dune itself is like such a roller
coaster of a book there's a lot going on
like Aaliyah's possession is super super
intense and super interesting especially
towards the end when the Baron finally
comes out that scene is so intense and
then gained EEMA
demon let her make her own choice oh god
it's so intense and it's the thing that
be she is possessed by a demon she's
possessed by a malignant human ego and
that's what a demon is like like you say
you're wrestling with demons you're
wrestling with something inside of
yourself a part of you and that's
exactly what's happening her it's a part
of the bearing is a part of her he's a
part of her genetic memory that's what
that's what's possessing her but it's
very sad because you learn at the end
that she could have overcome this
because Gani madad Leto did maybe if
Jessica had liked help and been there
when it actually started to get bad
maybe Jessica could have helped her
helped her overcome it in some way but
Jessica abandoned Aliyah she abandoned
Aliyah and went back to Cali there and
left Lilia on Arrakis
she tells Kadima I fled in terror of
what I'd created because there was all
these mini guys were warnings about
abomination so that's why guys held in
Ohio in the first book she's like oh my
god the child is an abomination killer
killer like what the but yeah so yeah
just a Leah's possession so terribly
tragic because she didn't have a choice
in any of this she didn't she was any
other and it's really sad it's very sad
but at the same time it's true for Paul
as well he really didn't choose any of
this he was just kind of forced into it
he was forced into the desert and he did
what he did to survive I guess but I
feel like in alia it's way worse because
she's like a chow
baby and then she's forced into like
complete awareness with all these other
entities all vying for just I guess the
what what would I call this is all vying
for like presents like space in the
consciousness in the awareness and it's
just so overwhelming and in the end you
see them all come out and they're like
frightened and angry and just every
emotion imaginable it's like it's very
intense and it's so it's so sad to see
or be destroyed and it's interesting to
see Jessica be consumed with horror
because she knows that a part of this is
her fault and she just sees that this is
this is my fault and she knows that it's
her fault and she has to live with that
I guess another thing in children I'm
doing that I really didn't focus on in
the and the ultimate guide was there's
kind of a weird little I guess it's not
weird there's like a little romance
almost that forms between Feridun and
the lady Jessica he's much younger but
the lady just goes of course a very
beautiful woman she's described as being
very beautiful so there's kind of like a
little he's got into that I see and I
feel like he's kind of fallen in love
with her a little bit but it's weird
because he ends up having to marry
ghanima and yeah that's the thing about
the video if you want if you've watched
it there's kind of inconsistencies and
the ages of the twins in the art because
in the do miniseries late I was much
older but in the book like so anga nema
are both tiny tiny children right so
it's like I guess in the in the movie
it's like you can't really get a kid to
really you can't I don't I don't know
how that you have you have to be like
the best child actor ever to pull off
Leto and ganene because there are adults
in human bodies but in in the books
Feridun finds out that he's gonna have
to marry Geneva who's like a little
child so he's like and then she says
never make that mistake again she's like
I might look like a child but I'm not a
child still kind of weird and even in um
beginning a children are doing it
actually even says that Leto Guinea ma
had participated in the spiced orgy
which is really weird to me that's
really weird I get that they have like I
get
they have adult minds but they do not
have adult bodies and that's very weird
but in in the opening it's still guarded
looking at the twins and he says these
twins of have shared in the spice orgy
and he says like I said they're not
children but they look like items I
don't know that's a little weird but
whatever but it is weird it's a child
but with an adult's mind not just an
adult's mind they're they're millions of
years old they have memories that
stretch back all the way through
back back back when and yeah it makes
them creepy just like alia was creepy
and doun they are quite creepy and
children of doing I think and a lot of
ways and he even Jessica's totally
freaked out by lado she's like holy crap
this demon child this this uh it's I
love that scene where she's talking to
him and she thinks that she's in control
of the situation and in the end she
realizes wait this dude is literally
manipulating my very he's he's he's
manipulating me through voice and I
didn't even realize it she comes to the
realization suddenly and she's like holy
[ __ ] like what aren't you well yeah I
love children doing it is I I don't even
like to rank the books I know that God
Emperor is my favorite but I also love
children of doing and I love dune and I
love Dumas I I love them all and I also
I love chapter house and heretics as
well I know a lot of people don't like
this final two as much but I enjoy them
and honestly I even enjoy I enjoy some
other Ryan Herbert stuff see that's the
thing it is it is different reading
Brian her but you kind of just have to
kind of like separate it in your mind if
you have to because it is Ryan Herbert
and Kevin J Anderson they're different
writers and the style is very different
it's like if george RR martin had a son
and then his son tried to write a song
by Sapphire and pick it up and finish it
that no George RR Martin's he's too good
like you can't like some writers are
just like they can't be emulated and so
like you're used to such amazing writing
and then you go to someone even if
they're good they're not Frank Herbert
they're not george RR martin they're not
you know Stephen King you know but it's
it's okay there okay I don't hate them
but and I know and I don't I'm not like
in love with them because people always
ask me and like do you Brian her books
what do you think you hate them that you
like them what do you think about them
and I'm like I mean I don't hate them I
don't love them I understand that people
view them as non-canonical and I totally
I totally get it cuz like I said before
I don't know I don't think that what
Brian Herbert did with the butler in
jihad is what Frank Herbert had in mind
at all I don't
I totally I'm totally against it because
like just in the in the first chapter
well if in the first chapter of doom
yeah once we gave herself over to
machines in the hopes that this was set
us free but this only permitted other
men with machines to enslave us other
men with machines that was what the
butler in Jena jihad was about it was
not like being afraid of AI necessarily
because AI we if you don't program a
computer to feel emotions and a feel
pain and I feel anger and hate then it
won't right but a person in control of
AI that is the real danger right because
we are the way we are because of these
evolutionary processes that have led us
this way but if we design a machine we
don't have to make it like us right the
real danger is the people in power of
those machines and that's what I think
is super scary I think that's oh that's
something that we are gonna have to face
pretty soon here hey we're gonna have to
face it people are gonna be in control
of lis some awesome awesome power pretty
soon here that's gonna happen see the
question of I think that you know shows
like West world doing a job of bringing
up the question of sentience right
because what is sentience we don't know
whether sentience is merely an emergent
property of a complex mind or if it's
something more because if it's merely an
emergent property of a complex mind that
means that a machine could totally be
sentient but if it is something more and
I don't know I I don't know I don't know
who knows but if it is something more
than I guess maybe even if a robot is
very complex
it seems to be sentient maybe it's still
not but then that's the question how
could we ever know that how could we
ever know it and if it is Sinti and it
is feeling pain that's a huge problem
that's a huge problem and I just I just
fear so much for it but this
conversation is getting a little bit off
the rails so I think we're gonna stop it
here thank you guys for listening and
thank you guys so much for supporting my
videos check me out on patreon peace out
dudes